FEMALE SPEAKER: So I'm really
excited about our next speaker,
because I worked closely
with her until recently.
And before I say who she is,
let's watch a video about her.
PAVNI DIWANJI: To
me, when I program,
it feels like I'm
creating something,
and once these creative
juices are flowing,
then I can bring
them everywhere I go.
I grew up in a city in western
India called Ahmedabad.
My mom worked as a bank manager.
At the time, you don't think
about these things, right?
It's only afterwards,
you're grown up,
and you're looking around
and you're like, boy,
that was unusual to have
actually a working mother.
My dad worked for IBM.
Think I was in
seventh grade, and he
was trying to get me
excited about programming
for the first time in
the language BASIC.
My dad's like, well,
you should learn
so you can enter
this competition.
I'm like, oh, that sounds good.
Really I have never looked back.
Once I got my hands dirty,
I was like, this is amazing.
I remember this
day very clearly.
I showed up to the university,
and I'm looking around.
In my whole class,
I'm the only woman.
And I'm like, I guess I'm going
to have to get used to this,
because it's also
a four-year degree.
If girls are showing
inclination towards sciences,
we have to support them and
we have to encourage them.
We have two daughters,
and I think my older one
is, right now, into
computer games.
So I'm taking that as a win.
My dad mortgaged
his office, $10,000.
I knew that could
last me one quarter.
So my mission, when
I came to Standford,
was to find a way to
fund my education.
I made a big list of
all of the professors.
I went to them, and I
said, here's what I can do.
Can you take a chance on me?
Some of them shouted at me.
One of them really kicked
me out of the office,
and I cried for a bit, and
then the next morning, I
went to the next
person on the list.
So I think my, don't give
up gene, really helped me.
I graduated in '92.
The company I wanted to work
for was Sun Microsystems,
because it was where a
lot of hot engineers were.
At the time, C++ was
the language of choice,
but it was fairly complex,
and a lot of programmers
didn't really like it.
This little team of
eight people deep in Sun
were designing a new
programming language called OAK.
And OAK became JAVA,
and then just launched,
and it became a huge
overnight success.
It was tremendously exciting.
We would come to work every day,
and there was a huge fan base.
And we had no idea
when we put it out,
we had no idea how
much of a success
this was going to become.
And then, James
Gosling had this idea
that this programming
language can be really, really
useful even on the server side.
And no one was looking
at that area at all,
and so I said, I'll step
up and I'll look at it.
And then servlets were born.
I think you can hardly go
to a website today that
doesn't deploy the technology.
I think spam is awful.
It clutters up everyone's life.
What makes it very
hard is also what
intrigues me about the problem.
It's almost like you're
playing chess with someone.
There's a human being
on the other side,
and there's us on
this side trying
to figure out how
to take them out.
I'm thinking about
the problem every day.
There's got to be
a better answer.
And that's what led to the
creation of my second company
MailFrontier.
The idea is, can we
take Gmail and bring it
to schools, and
universities, and companies?
And I found this
incredibly exciting.
I picked it up as
my 20% project.
20% projects at Google
are like, for 20%
of your time you're allowed
to do whatever you want.
Gmail was created this way.
Google Maps was
created this way.
Fast forward four years,
and what we achieved
was Google Apps for Business.
Most major universities in
the world today use that.
My kids' school uses that.
I would say it's the most
fast-paced project at Google.
I am driving the profiles
and pages effort,
and we've just gotten started.
We have so many good things
coming down the pipeline.
Success, to me, for Google+
pages, means every business,
every band, every
artist, will have a page,
a Google+ page where they
will all be using Google+.
I would declare victory if
I have changed the world,
if I have created something
that a lot of people
use that have made a
difference in their lives.
And Google makes it
really easy to do that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Well,
let's welcome [APPLAUSE]
our VP of engineering
at Google Pavni Diwanji.
When this video was made, she
was the director it appears.
Today she runs our spam
fighting efforts and Google Kids
efforts.
She, as you saw in the video,
founded and led Google Apps
for Business, and other
enterprise products,
and also helped start and
lead profiles and pages effort
for Google+.
Prior to joining Google, Pavni
was a serial entrepreneur
who started and sold multiple
successful companies.
She managed the communication
and client software division
encompassing email,
instant messaging,
and toolbar products
and Excite@Home.
She started her career,
as you saw in the video,
at Sun Microsystems as
a software engineer.
And she is the one who
helped make servlet happen.
She's won numerous
entrepreneurship awards
and holds several
patents in the areas
of distributed systems
and networking.
I also have the pleasure of
working closely with Pavni,
and it amazes me, her energy,
her unstoppable attitude,
and she never take
no for an answer.
So let's welcome Pavni on board.
PAVNI DIWANJI: Yeah, it
was a rough introduction,
wouldn't you agree?
It's hard to talk after that.
So I thought maybe I
can spend 10 minutes
and talk a little
bit about my journey.
And then I can open
it up for questions,
and we can just take it where--
it's a small enough audience.
We should be able to, I
think, have a conversation.
But before I start, one question
I have is, how many of you
are students?
Just for my
[INAUDIBLE], awesome.
And how many of you are
already in the workforce?
Wow, OK, cool.
It's pretty divided.
So I think the things
I want to talk about
is things that,
the qualities that
have helped make a difference
for myself, and hopefully
through that process,
motivate to you guys
to go conquer your own
moon-shots or your own dreams.
So, I was very fortunate.
I started as a kid
in India, and my dad,
as you saw in the
video, worked for IBM.
And one of the things
he did early on
is, he used to take me
to work all the time.
At that time, there
were no computers,
there were only punch cards
and punch card machines.
I'm kind of old, I guess.
But it was very good, because
getting that exposure--
and he would take me, he used
be a hardware engineering
and would do calls, and he
would take me on the calls.
And he would teach
me as we'd go along.
And it kind of sparked
that early interest in me.
Now, every Sundays,
he would also
give us, me and my brother
both, a screwdriver
and a soldering
iron, and we would
have to go around the house
fixing things that didn't work.
That part was not
too exciting for me,
but the computers stuck on,
and they have served me well,
and I've never really
looked back on my interest.
So I was one of those people
who was fortunate enough
to know what I was
passionate about early on.
Now, it doesn't always happened,
but in my case, it was.
Now, the other thing, I was
very good at math at school,
and my parents
always encouraged me.
Whatever I was good at, they
would encourage me to do that.
For example, I was
an avid reader,
and there was no reading
limit in my house.
I also remember, I
had a working mother,
but early on she didn't
work because there
were no day cares.
And I remember in fourth
grade, she came to me,
and she sat our
family down, and she
said well, I want
to make a change.
I want to go back to work, and
it's important for my own good.
And we listened, and
she explained to us
why it would mean changes
to us, and we listened.
And I realize now,
looking back on it,
how unusual that experience was.
Most kids in my school
didn't have working moms,
and didn't have to
make any adjustments.
And here I had
both my parents who
were great role models to me.
And this is what, I have
two daughters, as you saw,
and I really try hard to
encourage their passions.
Now, my older one, has
a passion for writing,
and also, unusually, science
fiction and Minecraft.
And, like I said, I try to
encourage her passions, too.
And my younger on is
more, it looks to me,
right now, that she's much more
into science and engineering.
So, now when I choose computer
science for my undergrad,
and as I showed, I arrived
at the engineering school,
the shock was quite immense.
It's hard to capture.
You show up, and you're
the only girl in the class.
And you look around,
and it's, to me, it's
a big test for your own self.
Can I still do it?
I asked myself, and I said,
yup, you know, it's OK.
I'll just learn how to
be in this environment.
And I think the big learning
lesson is, do what it takes.
Follow your interest,
and if you're having fun,
than the rest of it is
going to fall in place.
Now, when I decided to
follow further education
and come to US,
Stanford accepted me.
And I also remember the day
when some of my relatives
came to my mother to
have a special talk.
And they said that
it better not send me
to US and to Stanford
for further education.
And she said, why?
It's such a great opportunity.
And they said, well, if she
gets such highly educated,
then she won't find a match.
And I remember my mom
towering, she stood up,
and she said, let
me worry about that.
So I thought that was the
best thing that she could do,
and she turned around, and she
looked at me, and she said,
you're going to do what
you need to do, and let
me worry about these people.
So, financially, it was also
not easy, as we talked, right?
And thinking ahead,
the fact that my dad
made such a big
sacrifice to send me here
to further my studies, that gave
me a lesson of responsibility.
There were a lot of sacrifices
done to get me to where I was,
and so I did not want to
fritter away my opportunity.
I wanted to work hard,
and it was deep within me
to prove myself, because
a lot was riding on it.
And that work
ethic comes from, I
think, that lesson
of responsibility
that my parents gave.
Now, coming to
Stanford I told you
guys story about the early
lesson on don't give up.
But I also want to
talk a little bit
about my first class I took
was computer networking.
Now, it was easy for
me to top in India.
I was always in the
first, second, rank.
You come to Stanford,
and you're surrounded
by super smart people, people
who are much smarter than you.
And it is intimidating.
I go to my first lesson, it
was computer networking lesson.
The professor, David Cheritan,
he stood up and said,
OK, first homework assignment.
And we're all getting
our notebooks out.
And he said, I want you
guys to go and read TCP/IP.
Now, for geeks in
the audience, this
is the protocol that
powers everything.
And he's standing up,
and he's saying to us,
all students, fresh, saying,
yeah, we can do it better.
So I think I was like,
that's impossible.
We can't do that in
two weeks, right?
He's crazy.
And I think that what I
learned in that two weeks,
is it was not impossible.
In fact, a lot of students
wrote better things, right?
So what it taught
me is that you have
to think from first principles,
nothing is impossible,
and working with smarter
people, encouraging
diverse environments,
and taking on challenges
does change the world.
So, this was my first
lesson at Stanford.
When I got a job doing
backups for Stanford
to pay for my tuition.
And I also remember the first
time-- they gave me an office,
and I went into the
office, and there
was a next computer and a
Macintosh-- two Macintoshes,
actually.
And I'm looking,
and in my mind, I'm
thinking there must
be 10 people office,
we must be time sharing.
So I looked at them, and I
said, so what's my time slot
to come into this office?
And they're looking
at me saying,
no, no, this is your office.
I'm like, really?
I get to have three computers?
Wow!
So that's the other
thing, resources
were [INAUDIBLE], for
me, it was like a kid
being in a candy store.
And then it was only left up to
me to make a difference, right?
So that was huge.
So fast forward
two, three years,
I'm looking for my new job, I
knew I wanted to work for Sun.
I had an offer from
Silicon Graphics,
but I went to interview
at Sun, and I really
liked the people there.
And the engineers
there excited me,
and they were trying to
build this thing called,
remote procedure
calls, RPCs, and I
thought I could really
help them do it better.
But they decided not to hire me.
So I got a call saying,
no, you're really bright,
and we really like you, but
we don't have any openings
right now, so no.
And I was really depressed,
and then one of my friends
looked at me and said,
since when do you
take no for an answer?
Pick up the phone
and call the manager.
So I had to pump
myself up to do that.
And I spent 15
minutes-- I didn't
listen to anything
she had to say--
and all I talked about
is how I could change
what they were doing for better,
and how they're making mistakes
that I could help fix, right?
And after 15 minutes she just
said, OK, let me call you back.
Give me a day or so
to think about it.
Then, five minutes,
I'm not kidding you,
five minutes later, she called
me and said, you're hired.
So the lesson was, don't
take no for an answer,
there are too many
people in life
who spend time
saying no to people.
Don't listen to them, right?
Before I went to
JAVA team, there
was another team I was with,
and I was very frustrated.
I was doing really
well as an engineer,
but I would go in to
these large meetings
and no one would listen to me.
And I had good ideas, and
no one would listen to me.
So, one thing I do very
well is I ask for help.
And so there was a distinguished
engineer in my team,
and so I pulled him aside and
said, do you not like my ideas?
And he says, no,
they're fabulous.
So I said, then why
is no one listening
to me in the meetings?
And he paused for a
second, and then he
said, well, you just
hike up the volume.
Try a few things,
learn to shout.
He even told me,
get on the table.
Do whatever it takes, so I
took his advice to heart,
and in the next meeting,
I'm like, right.
I cleared up my throat,
and I was going in,
and then right in the beginning
of the meeting, I shouted.
I started shouting at
the top of my voice.
And there was a hush.
And then everyone looked at me
and said, why are you shouting?
And it's like, it's because
you weren't listening to me.
But anyway, do whatever it takes
to make your dream real, right?
And then a few years down, after
JAVA happened and everything,
it was super exciting for me.
My career had gotten off
to a fabulous start at Sun.
And then one of my coworkers
came to me and said,
let's do a startup.
This was 1998, it
was an unusual time.
A lot of people were
breaking off to do companies,
and I'm like, no.
I'm doing so well at Sun, I
don't want to give it all up.
So it took me a few
months to figure this out,
but then I said, you know?
Maybe challenging myself
would be a good thing.
And so I broke off and we
started my first company,
which was a search company
called [INAUDIBLE].
And it was an
amazingly fun ride,
and what I learned
through that experience
was taking big risks matter,
challenging yourself.
If you challenge yourself,
you might surprise yourself.
I found things I didn't know
I had in terms of talent.
I was a CEO, I'd never
done sales before.
I hadn't taken an MBA
class before, right?
But I just kind of worked my way
through it, and in the process,
I found that was actually
a really good negotiator.
It's something I
would have never found
if I'd just stayed at Sun and
continued to be an engineer.
So, I think my learning
there was-- and it also
really grew my confidence
and taught me new skills.
So sometimes, throwing
yourself into a new problem
really grows you and grows
your perception of you
and what you can
do with your life.
So, fast forward again,
and I've been at Google,
I think, since 2005, so eight
and a half years, long time.
When I came over,
I didn't think I
was going to last for
very long because I
had to startup bug in me.
But I went through
the interview,
and I was so challenged
in that interview.
It was over three days,
and so many people,
and they were asking me
really hard questions, right?
And I interviewing
for a managing job,
like a director
job, and they were
asking me to code on
the whiteboard, right?
And afterwards, I remember
talking to the recruiter,
and I said, I think there's been
some mistake because they're
asking me to code, which
I don't mind doing,
but you know I'm interviewing
for a managing job.
And he's like, no, we
do this to everyone.
I'm like, OK.
But what I learned was that
through that interview,
I took it as an
experience, because I
learned that there are so
many smart people here.
And I really want
to learn from them.
In the interview,
I think someone
who interviewed me had
invented Google Ads.
And I'm like, wow.
So it in my gut, I
came home, and I'm
like, if they're going
to offer me a job, then
I'm going to take it because
this feels right to me.
And my first four years, I
remember coming in to Google,
and I had a bunch of big jobs.
I was managing Google
Calendar, and Blogger,
and a bunch of projects.
And then there was this
three engineer team,
and they had this idea that
what if we take Gmail and use it
for universities, and
schools, and businesses.
And I just come
from startup land,
I had gone through
the hell of setting up
an exchange server
for my startup.
And I also knew
that in schools, we
were using really
backwards tools.
And I saw the opportunity
to have the impact.
And even though it
was a small project,
I adopted it as a 20% project.
And this is one
of the-- there are
lots of fabulous
things about Google,
but one of the things
I love the most
is that they really
give you the freedom
to figure out what you're
passionate about and go for it.
And the other
fabulous thing is, I
remember, I have this
really concrete memory,
the first building I stepped
in was right next door, here.
And one day I was just
doing my business,
and sitting on my desk,
and this guy friend
came by and introduced me.
And he was just
sitting two desks down,
and he was the founder of Gmail.
And I'm like, oh
my God, oh my God.
I have arrived, that's
what I said to myself.
So anyways, it's really
humbling, but at the same time
I find it very empowering.
So, last 10, 15
minutes what I've
talked about is, follow
your gut and passion,
don't let anyone
else say otherwise.
Don't take no for an answer.
Do whatever it takes
to follow your dreams.
And take risks.
Challenging yourself
and keeping growing
is the only way to grow.
And then the last thing
is, find an environment
that supports you.
Surround yourself with
people who support you,
and the rest will follow.
So I hope my story inspires
you to find your own,
and pursue your own moon-shots
and dreams, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So, I'm happy to answer
questions if we have time.
AUDIENCE: Hi, so
based on your story,
I have something very similar.
I completed my
bachelor's and I wanted
to get my master's over here,
and my mom was OK with that.
And my aunt came to her and
said, why are you doing that?
She should get married now.
PAVNI DIWANJI: It's
a common problem.
AUDIENCE: And so same thing
happened after a completed
a master's.
People asked me, when
are you getting married?
And after some
time, I got married.
And people asked me, so
when are we having babies?
And the worst thing about
this is nobody asked me
what I'm doing with my career.
It's just sad.
So my question to you is,
what would you suggest?
How do we change the
society around us?
PAVNI DIWANJI: I think I'm a
big believer in what Margaret
Mead's code I think
everyone knows it,
everything starts
with an individual,
don't underestimate
the power you have.
My dad also always
says that when
you come across a
challenge, 100% of the time,
the answer is within
you, not around you.
So look within, and
what I would say
to you is why are you
waiting for them to ask?
Tell them.
Tell them what you
want to do, right?
So that would be answer.
I don't think this is
easy, any big changes
in numbers in society, they
all have to start small.
Every big change
has to start small.
And the soldiers and individuals
who are in the revolution
are what is going to make
a difference in the end.
So this is where all of
you are very important.
And this is why we are
here on a Saturday, night?
Because we all think
we can make a change.
As Yoki also said the
same thing earlier.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So you have an
amazing drive, an amazing self
confidence, and I that was
really inspiring to hear.
And I think a lot of people
the room probably have similar,
if we made it here, we have
the same kind of drive.
And I think-- I lead
the women in tech group,
and I think sometimes
it's really easy
to say, follow your passion,
do whatever it takes.
And that can be really
hard, and really alienating,
and really lonely.
And so I think my question is,
how do we lower the bar so you
don't need that amazing drive,
that iron drive to make it?
How do we make it
easier for those
who don't have that
to join us here
in this really
amazing profession?
PAVNI DIWANJI: I think
it's a very good question,
and there are a couple of
facets of answers I would give.
One of the things
I tell people is,
if things are not working
where you are, then change it.
You have the power to change it.
You try once or twice.
This is why I,
personally, love Google,
and this is why I've been here
for eight and a half years,
is I think it's incredibly
humble and supporting
environment, right?
To get your voice
heard it's no problem.
We're solely
data-focused, right?
We debate openly
about ideas, we are
fairly collaborative
as a company,
and I think these are really
good embodiments for women
engineers, too.
We like that, right?
So find an
environment like that.
The other point I would
make is, surround yourself
with people who are
going to lift you, right?
It's incredibly important.
Early on I realize-- and it
doesn't have to be women--
early on I realized that, I need
help, comes really easy for me
to say.
And I realize it's not so
easy for a lot of people,
but one of the
things I realized is
as soon as I say that, I always
have a hand raised, someone
raising their hand
saying, I'll help you.
So I've had good fortune to
have good social backing,
like having great friends,
and also having great mentors
who can tell me
what I need to do.
So, I think that is
going to make it easy.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
part of-- thank you,
I'll stand over here-- so
I'm part of a tech boot camp,
and I'm the first
woman in my program.
There have been about
50 students so far,
and I'm the only
woman that has ever
been enrolled in the program.
And one thing that I
find that's interesting
is that a lot of
the men program,
they're not really aware
of their own biases that
can create an environment that
make it difficult for women
to get into.
So for example, for the
first week in the program,
the guys got together and they
made a page called Bro Hacks.
And it was all about hacks for
guys to make really cool code.
And I've been made an honorary
bro since then, which is great.
But I think that there
are little things that
can create a very difficult
environment for women
to get into or it
seems intimidating.
And I wanted to see
if you or anybody else
here have any thoughts on
how we can make men more
aware of the biases
that they have.
Because it is very
difficult when
you walk into a room
and it's only men.
Or you walk into a recruiting
event or a networking event
and people assume that you're a
recruiter and not a developer.
So I just wanted to
get your thoughts
on that, how we can bring in
men to the conversation, too?
PAVNI DIWANJI: I think
someone, go ahead.
There's one minute left, OK.
So a quick-- I would say
there's no magic answers.
Unfortunately it is
what it is, but I
think we have the
power to change it.
So what I do in these
situations is I just stand up
and I say, here's
who I am, and here's
where I'm going to add value,
and here's my role, right?
So you do have to
be the spokespeople.
We have to be our
own spokespeople
is what I'm saying, probably
that's the best way.
There's no magic answers that's
going to transform society.
The power is in this room.
The power is here.
I think we have to be
the revolutionists.
We have to be the leaders.
AUDIENCE: So, I have
one more question.
So like someone
had mentioned, you
have this amazing
self-confidence.
And I think a lot of women,
when they arrive at college,
I was one of them, but that
was the first time I had ever
learned about computer science.
And there are these
boys in the class that
have been doing it since
they were like, 11.
And there's been
a couple articles,
there's been more and more
talk-- not just about men--
but there's something
called tech privilege,
where there's people that
have been doing it forever,
and someone coming in later,
it's often very intimidating.
And then you mentioned
during your talk
that at Sun Microsystems
you knew you were right.
And you had ideas and
they were brilliant.
So how did you
believe in yourself?
How did you believe that
you had great ideas,
and that they were right,
and people should listen
to you instead of assuming that
other people, because they've
been in industry
longer, just knew better
because they have
more experience?
PAVNI DIWANJI: You didn't.
I didn't know I was right.
That was part of my story,
but maybe I can tell it again.
I think initially, I
also got down, right?
I didn't talk about all the
low points in my career.
There's more lows than
highs in career and in life,
but I think that don't give
up rides me out, normally.
And I have this little back room
in my house where I go to cry,
as well.
So, I think it's OK.
I think that's what I said,
I think on the Sun one,
I think I didn't
know I was right.
I knew something was off, that
I was having all these ideas,
and there was this little
voice inside of me that said,
this doesn't look right.
So I went and I consulted
someone offline.
That was the key thing.
This person, other
engineer, one on one,
I sat down and said,
what do you think?
And he said, no, you're right,
and you should speak up.
And that was what gave me
the power to do what I did.
So everyone has lows and highs.
Men do too, right?
So I think the question
is, do we have techniques?
Do we cultivate
techniques to surmount it?
And I I'm a big
proponent of mentoring.
Not for the sake of it, but
find someone who you look up to.
Cultivate that relationship so
that you can go and ask them
for help when you need it.
We're done, I think.
Thank you everyone.
Thank you.